Thanks for clarifying the Mercola art of the problem today is they write these articles not for specific types of disease like cancer drives
We does I would agree so it's just like with anything you just got to be
Careful of the quainty
Everything with you. I mean, I think everybody's different first of all
And I think there's some people that would do great on a low-fat diet like that for a period of time
And I think there's a lot of people that do great on
NAD supplements. I'll tell you I can tell you
half a dozen people that reacted horribly to NAD supplements not cancer patients
That got out hard computations and all sorts of problems. So
Everybody's different. That's the thing to remember
So we gotta be careful not to speak dogmanically in anything that we do
But when you are reading health things there's a lot of information out there
And I have people that send me
Instagram videos and
Facebook videos of people that are
Quarantical at your paths or natural functional medicine doctors that make claims that are just
That are just at just that are wrong for everybody
And some are right but they're not right for cancer patients or some are right
But they're not right for everybody, but they use such dogmanic language
Okay, somebody made a video like is copper bad for you? That's nonsense
And he went off on this whole thing about copper is good for you and we need copper
But he's just completely wrong
You know copper toxicity is a huge issue
Um, since we put copper pipes in our homes since we you know for
Many centuries use copper pans for cookie
Copper toxicity is very common and it can be a cause for cancer because it leads to
deficiency or we should say a relative zinc deficiency
A lot of people have ill health because they have a copper overload
Um, and that is an issue um, so and some people just
I don't know what they're talking about and some people
Um are do know what they're talking about that doesn't relate to cancer and some people
Do know what they're talking about, but then they make it so dogmatic like everybody should do this
Which then it's just not true not everybody should do anything so or very few things so
Um, just be be aware of those things